last video I was at the ashen Graybiel
spatial orientation lab at Brandeis
University and while I was there one of
the teams that they have an artificial
gravity laboratory okay so it's a room
that rotates no one has invented science
fiction gravity generators yet but if
you have a theoretical spaceship going
to Mars and you want to generate
apparent gravity to keep astronauts
healthy and that's what you do you would
spin up the ship and use centrifugal
force and that lab is the research
prototype how do humans deal with a very
strange gravitational environment the
first thing that you should do is try to
push yourself off the wall and align
your body with the direction of the
resultant don't worry little dangerous
it is almost impossible to envision
long-duration spaceflight without
artificial gravity the best way to study
artificial gravity on earth is to build
a rotating environment we started
designing it in the mid-80s
ideally we want to study its effects on
the human body and we want to learn also
how to pre adapt astronauts to the force
of artificial gravity in 99.9% those
will be highly dysfunctional individuals
until adaptive they have NASA standard
sick bags for everyone by the way I was
required to keep one in my back pocket
throughout just in case because if you
tilt your head too fast your inner ear
has no idea of what's going on and
things go wrong very quickly you know
move your arm and try to go as straight
as you can
Oh Oh you shouldn't move your head
yeah yeah videos better yet you can
adapt move your arms and try to feel
this force that is disables are giving
my muscles I'll move my arms forward now
I'm forcing them I'm pushing against
force if you keep going at some point
you won't feel the force anymore oh
that's weird that's weird right that's
so weird
so now we are adapted so if I try doing
anything else I have adjusted to it but
that specific movement my used to that's
right
Wow one way to visualize this force is
for me to try and throw a little things
ball at you I will throw it straight at
you I feel that and now I'm gonna throw
it over there yeah and hopefully all
those artifacts are from the Coriolis
force it's not a real force acting on
the ball but it looks like one when
you're in that weird rotating
environment have a look at this 360
degree image of the lab now it's low
distorted because it's from a single
camera in the middle but it's close
enough here's the tricky part the
circumference of a circle is longer the
further out you go from the middle but
because everything in that circle is
rotating at the same speed once around
every six seconds things on the outside
have farther to travel so they're moving
at a faster speed than things on the
inside on the outside we're moving
pretty fast but that camera in the
middle is just spinning on the spot so
let's mark the sideways speed that
everything is moving out relative to the
rest of the world
Green is fast red is slow when you throw
a ball across that room it keeps that
sideways speed that it had when it
left your hand as it travels into slower
moving areas of the room now at the edge
that was fine it was going the same
speed as everything around it so it
looked like it aim for the center
but by the time it starts to get there
it's a missile flying outwards compared
to everything around it now from the
outside that makes sense after it leaves
your hand the ball just moves in a
straight line from the inside it looks
like there's a force suddenly sending it
sideways and that is the Coriolis force
and it's not something your brain has
evolved to deal around the question that
lab needs to answer is can humans adapt
to that over time and if so how long
does it take them to come back down to
work can you bring up to zero bring your
hands down and try to swing your arms in
front of you you'll be adapted there are
no unusual forces on your arms but you
feel it right yeah and now you have to
react thank you so much to everyone at
the Ashton Grable spatial orientation
lab at Brandeis University pull down the
description for more about them and
their work
you